when does the rule don't be boring come
into play from beginning to end the
least we want is not to be bored I mean
I go to the movies and see screeners
scandalously I'm going less and less the
theaters and looking more and more
screeners I used to feel guilty about
not going to the theaters now I feel
guilty about not screening the screeners
and and the the reason is usually I am
bored I think most art is is pretty bad
most paintings most sculpture most
literature most music is lousy now that
also may seem like a cynical in a an a
dark thing to say but it's the opposite
of that the truth is that the it the
stuff that is contemporary much of it is
going to be pretty bad some of it will
be brilliant what happens is that it the
bad stuff falls away you go I was in New
York not too terribly long ago and I was
in the museum of the Metropolitan Museum
of Art one of my favorite museums and I
didn't see a single painting there that
wasn't timeless and eternal that didn't
deserve to be there and you could get
the impression from that that paintings
are somehow worthy all the time well you
don't realize a lot of people don't
realize is that for every painting that
hangs at the Met there are 10,000 stupid
worthless jerky amateur paintings now
there's nothing wrong I think it's one
of other people tried to paint and tried
to be creative and took a shot at it but
it's unusual that it's worth bothering
somebody else about that is to say
there's something in the work that
merits the attention and the
consideration of the time of an audience
an observer in film because it is
contemporary even more so television
because it's in our face now there
hasn't been the chance for the stuff the
bad stuff to drop away so we think that
it's uniquely bad when it
it isn't it's just as bad as other as
other art fortunately the little bit of
really really good stuff is enough to
change your life and and make it worth
engaging all of it all of the stuff so
that you do see the the the good stuff
there's people people say why don't they
make good movies now like they used to
in the 30s and the 40s
did they make good movies in the 30s and
the way they did there were a lot of
really good ones
but they were also a lot a lot of lousy
ones we just don't remember them I think
50 60 years from now they'll be saying
why don't they make good movies like
they did back in the early you know new
millennium because the people will have
forgotten the hunger game I'm not a big
fan of the because I think people are
going to forget about it but they're
going to remember the imitation game
they were in two games today I guess
isn't that the movie that yeah about
touring and so on so we the least we
want when I say don't be boring I'm
saying that's the very least that I want
from a work of art we're talking now
about dramatic narratives you know I was
at the Louvre in Paris and I saw the
Mona Lisa
among others how much time did I spend
with it a minute if I'd spent 3 minutes
with it that would have been a long time
if I sat quietly now for just a few
seconds you'd feel how how how heavily
time ways do you know I'm just waiting
for see if I get quite even for two
seconds you get nervous and you jump and
I don't blame you that's my that's my
point I say sorry uh no no no not at all
that's your help you're having me the
the but the most we want from that's the
least we want I have a deal with my wife
which is if I start to nod out during
movie she's supposed to let me do that
unless some snore
and wheezing and spraying everybody
around us and then bringing disgrace and
discredit and humiliation upon us it's
up to the movie to keep me awake and the
fact that matter is that the I used to
like fight it if I started to drift
during the movie I would fight it like
you know hey sort of I got breath and
try to you know pay to choose now I if I
start to drift that's it I'm going I'm
going to nod out in this one it just
does not worth seeing you know I've
walked into movies where I was really
weary hadn't slept very well but it was
a good movie and it woke me up so that's
the least we want don't be boring and if
that's what you do that's an incredible
achievement but again that's the bottom
that's what's the top and the top is I
want my life changed completely the way
great art does I want it turned upside
down and transmogrified I want to be
transported and that's what Breaking Bad
did to me that's what the Sopranos did
to me I just my life is different and
you know constantly because of my
exposure to to that that great art and
that's what great art should do at the
top end it should just change your life
forever
you